[Music]
clay targets are made to be destroyed
the very first time they're used
manufactured in multiple colors these
inverted saucers are used as practice
targets and can be launched by hand or
through automated machines also referred
to as clay pigeons these targets are not
actually made of clay they're made with
pitch a ceramic type material or resin
since the 1920s this French company has
been producing clay saucers for both
target practice and competitions
including the Olympics the founder
invented the first automated target
moulding machine in 1947 pitch targets
are made from petroleum pitch a
substance derived from crude oil and
calcium carbonate commonly known as talc
talc is the filler while petroleum pitch
is the binding agent which solidifies
into a hard brittle material the
chocolates to the factory heated at 176
degrees Fahrenheit
a technician transfers the talc from the
truck to a heated storage silo a screw
conveyor moves the tout from the silo to
the blender tank mixing it with the
pitch
[Music]
the petroleum pitch arrives to the
factory heated to 392 degrees the pitch
is transferred to a heated storage silo
and pumped into a blender every 10
seconds 22 pounds of petroleum pitch and
64 pounds of talc are released into the
blender the materials cool as soon as
they leave the heated silos a gas boiler
reheats the ingredients in 509 degree
oil the hot oil circulates in pipes
around the blender heating the pitched
out mixture to about 390 degrees this
process changes the consistency to a
paste the paste flows from the blender
to the automatic molding machine this
valve cuts the flow at regular intervals
to time the injections into the target
shaped bolts the machine compresses the
paste while cooling it with water so
that it solidifies a transfer device
moves the targets onto a conveyor belt
one at a time as they move to the next
conveyor belt the molds are flipped
right-side up even though the molds are
still hot they've remained soft and
pliable as the targets continue to cool
and Harden a separating device lines
them up for the conveyor belts that go
to the paint chambers
the paint is made primarily of carbonate
and biodegradable powdered pigment a
technician pours a pre-measured amount
of water and a bag of pigment into a
mixer the mixer combines the ingredients
together once the water and pigment have
blended together a pre-measured amount
of carbonate is added to the mixer along
with a binding and thickening agent
after additional blending the paint is
ready the targets move from the conveyor
belt onto spinning holders which carry
the targets through the paint chamber
[Music]
inside a sprayer coats the spinning
targets with paint the targets exit the
chamber wet and cold
another separator divides the targets
onto two conveyor belts which carry them
through a hot air tunnel for 30 seconds
to dry the paint
the conveyor belt feeds the targets to a
machine which piles them in stacks clay
pigeons can be manufactured in several
sizes Olympic regulation size is the
largest containing a width of 4 inches
a smaller target is used for training
purposes and contains a width under four
inches regardless of their size all
targets are engineered to remain stable
in flight while following the intended
trajectory and finally shatter one shot